[Musique]
nous contestons la méthode la
précipitation et la brutalité un samedi
après midi lors d'un conseil des
ministres consacré au cours d'un virus
comprennent une délibération secrètes
sur le 49-3 ça ça pose problème la
deuxième chose qui pose quand même c'est
que c'est la première fois qu'on le fait
sur la réforme des retraites la réforme
des retraites sur jacques bourdin ses
320 milliards d'euros c'est 15% du
produit intérieur brut
l'arrogance la brutalité et le cynisme
ne font pas une politique
et ça n'est pas de la noble politique si
on veut réhabiliter la politique il faut
écouter les oppositions il faut écouter
d'inquiétude des français et sur un
sujet aussi important que la question
des retraites il faut accepter de
prendre le temps comment est-ce qu'on
finance cette réforme des retraites
commencera prise en compte la pénibilité
quand est ce que seront éteints tous ces
régimes spéciaux qui sont
structurellement déficitaires comment
est ce qu'on fait pour éviter de prendre
dans la poche des régimes qui sont
excédentaires et qui sont des régimes en
réalité particulier parfaitement
autonome comme ceux des avocats tout
cela on n'a pas de réponse
il n'y a pas d'élément de financement
dans cette loi la loi a été discutée à
l'assemblée nationale avant même la fin
des travaux de la conférence de
financement donc c'est comme si dans un
budget vous votiez les dépenses et vous
n'étiez pas les recettes chacun comprend
c'est totalement absurde que le
gouvernement devait laisser vivre ce
texte il n'avait pas fait ailleurs donc
il devait le laisser vivre comment
peut-on comment dirais-je pour une
réforme aussi lourde faire dans la
précipitation
quand toutes les étapes encore une fois
auront été totalement raté le
gouvernement ne voulait pas s'expliquer
sur le fond de cette réforme
il avait les moyens de créer un débat de
fond au parlement sur ce sujet il ne le
voulait pas et il a préféré laisser
cette stratégie d'obstruction pourrir
petit à petit pour pouvoir ensuite
dégainer le 49 3 ce qui lui permet
maintenant de faire passer une réforme
qui n'a même pas été discuté
[Musique]